[Musique]
les photographies de presse gagnant du
prestigieux world press photo sont une
fenêtre unique sur le monde et c'est ce
qui a poussé car les deux monnaies à
devenir la porte parole de l'édition
2022 présenté à montréal est très fort
cette année les propositions
photographique toutes les photos ici
c'est un peu comme le pouls de ce qui se
passe à travers le monde des photos
comme à ma droite une photo qui montre
la guerre en ukraine c'est simplement
une statue un monument qui est décapitée
mais je trouve que l'image elle parle
d'elle-même en plus de la guerre en
ukraine il est aussi question de
conflits en afrique de déforestation en
amérique du sud et descendit qui ont
ravagé la planète le grand prix annuel a
été remis à une canadienne un braquage
dans cette photographie a été publiée
dans le new york times il s'agit de
croix en bois installée pour commémorer
la disparition de tous ses enfants
décédés au pensionnat autochtone de
kamloops
et
cette photographie est tout seul mettent
en lumière les préoccupations des
peuples autochtones au début car les
monnaies c'est une image qui met qui me
touche profondément des sujets qui qui
sont en plein dans l'actualité de la
dernière année
puis parce que ça touche toutes les
questions autochtones donc j'ai trouvé
que d'accepter ce rôle là cette année
c'était doublement symbolique en plus
des images gagnant du world press photo
2022 l'édition montréalaise présente une
exposition de l'équipe des décrypteurs
de radio canada sur les fausses
nouvelles il ya aussi une série baptisée
claire 107 ans une incursion dans le
quotidien d'une centenaire captée par
l'artiste justin la tour et demi ce
temps encore moi j'ai pas tout et listed
et puis c'est tellement bête maquette
photographique c'est tout le temps
d'aller un peu au bout de cette femme
non mais je pense qu'avant portait bien
laisser cris émouvante est essentiel
l'exposition world press photo montréal
est présenté au marché bonsecours
jusqu'au 2 octobre prochain ici vous sur
les prix mais radio-canada morin